Now that we've explored different variable types in Java,
and seeing how computers follow instructions like printing out a sentence,
let's take this a step further.
What if I wanted to program a smart coffee maker that would make me my favorite espresso,
but would also give other people their favorite kind of coffee.
Whether that's a latte,
or espresso, or something else.
Our program would have to know which person is asking for coffee,
and then follow a different set of instructions to get me an espresso,
and other people their favorite drink.
In this lesson, we will talk about how to build programs that make decisions like
this and can follow different sets of instructions based on the information we give it.
This is called control flow.
We use it to build programs together to do things like make a smart coffeemaker,
automatically set museum admission prices,
create a restaurant rating system and more.
And after, you'll have the tools you need to build
a program that follows any rules you specify.
Let's start by learning how computers make decisions.